[MUSIC PLAYING]
KEYUR GOVANDE: I'm the
chief architect at Etsy.
And we're here to talk
about Etsy's migration
to Google Cloud.
DANNY ROSEN: Awesome.
Thanks.
My name's Danny Rosen.
I'm the technical program
manager at Google.
I worked with Etsy on
their cloud migration,
which we're really excited
to talk to you about today.
KEYUR GOVANDE: So a quick
introduction to what is Etsy.
Etsy is the world's
largest marketplace
for unique and creative goods.
We have a community that
has over 2 million sellers,
39 million buyers, and
we have 50 million items
for sale on the site.
We're also heavily diverse.
30% of our engineers are
women, four out of six execs
are women, and we have
gender parity on the board.
A lot of the Etsy
sellers are also women.
For the vast majority
of them, Etsy
is their only source of income
and they're businesses of one.
So we take all of
that into account
as we make decisions
for the company.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So a little bit of
background about Etsy.
Etsy was founded in 2015--
sorry, in 2005.
This was a time that the cloud
did not exist as a concept.
We were solely in
the data center.
And in that time and era, we had
to build a lot of our own tech,
because there was not much
out there that we could use.
You may have heard of a little
daemon called StatsD that
was originally written by Etsy.
We have a bunch of CI/CD
tooling that we have open
sourced like deploy nature.
And we have a fairly popular
programming and engineering
blog at codeascraft.com.
The reason that I bring
that up is that we
used to be data center focused.
People who have worked in the
data center know this timeline.
You budget three
to six months out.
You order hardware.
It takes some time to come in.
Then you receive it.
If you rack and stack it.
Then you provision it.
You set up all the software
that you need on it before it
can finally enter production.
The timeline is really long.
And Etsy was finding that
this workflow was not scaling
as the site was growing.
And primarily, these are
the three main benefits
of the cloud.
Like there is compute capacity,
elasticity, and efficiency.
Etsy is trying-- the 50
million items that we
showed are completely unique.
They're not SKUs that
we can easily search.
So we needed a lot
of compute in order
to apply machine learning to
figure out, for example, what
are the items to show to
our sellers, what would
be the most compelling to them.
This was really hard
to do it correctly,
and at scale, and with
efficiency in the data center.
In Google Cloud, we can--
or in a cloud environment,
we can spin up
nodes really quickly
without having to spend up
front in purchasing the nodes
and getting them ready to go.
And the other thing
is efficiency.
For Etsy, the traffic
follows a pattern
that peaks in the day and
then slows down at night.
We are burning a lot of compute
keeping those boxes running 24
by 7 in the data center.
In a cloud environment,
again, this is not a problem.
When we don't need the
nodes, we turn them off.
It's efficient both from a
cost perspective and also
an environmental perspective.
So why Google Cloud?
DANNY ROSEN: It's
a good question.
Why Google Cloud indeed?
So there are four major aspects
of why Etsy chose Google Cloud.
The first is culture.
Google's culture
and Etsy's culture
follow really interesting
connectivity that we're
going to talk about in a sec.
The second is there's
a focus on ML.
If you haven't figured
that out already as part
of our marketing narrative, it's
really clear in the products
that we're pushing out and
how Etsy is implementing it.
It's pretty interesting.
Finally, the second or the
third, international data
centers.
There's a long list of
data centers we support.
And it works for Etsy's
global footprint.
And then finally, we both have
a really strong commitment
to sustainability,
making sure that we're
taking care of
the Earth together
and making the right
decisions for ourselves.
So we say culture.
And what does that
actually mean?
On the board, we have
two different articles.
The first is straight
out of the SRE book
about postmortem culture,
this idea of being blameless.
A while ago, a person named
John Allspaw from Etsy
actually wrote one of the
major pieces of this in Code
as Craft that's
referenced even today.
And when you look at blameless
and postmortem culture,
you ask yourself, well,
what's the big deal?
Why is this important?
And it's about
iterative learning.
Right.
It's about, hey,
we made a mistake.
And that's OK,
because we're thinking
for the long term
as a collective,
rather than for the short
term for somebody to blame.
The next thing is
machine learning.
Right?
So finding the right crocheted
octopus on Etsy, kind of hard.
How are you going to do it?
Machine learning.
Pretty clear.
Notably there are 4,444
crocheted octopuses
on etsy.com.
Totally not kidding.
This is not an edit.
Like feel free.
Yeah.
So if you need a crochet
octopus, this is where you go.
But Etsy's search engineering
team, also represented
in the room today,
is actively looking
at different ways of providing
good search results that
are relevant to queries
that users are putting in.
So searching for the word
couch really brings up
a couch, not a
pillow of a couch.
That's the idea.
Next thing is
international data centers.
Right.
And there's so many on the
board and maybe one day
a whole lot more as we grow.
But this falls in line
with Etsy's global plans,
Google's plans of expanding
and having good partners that
are tech-centric
and building out
in these different locations.
And then finally,
I think the thing
that is a little more
emotional but is relevant,
like I have a family.
And I'd like that family to
grow one day and to persist.
And if we take care of the Earth
and we're doing the right thing
sustainably with these big data
centers using a ton of power,
then we're going to make sure
that my family and your family
are going to have a
better place to live in.
And I think that as
a community in tech,
as we grow, the thing
that we're using is power.
We do so sustainably
and we think
about the broader ecosystem.
So that's why Google.
Let's talk a bit
about how we made
this work and the partnership
between the two teams.
So it began in December
of 2017 in New York City
in Eric Schmidt's side office.
There was a business
conversation
between lawyers, salespeople,
talking about how
we're going to make this work.
What's the contract look like?
And I'm sitting there
chewing on my fingernails
like, I don't know.
Right?
And the right people
in the room were
asking the right questions.
And we made it work.
We started our partnership
on that day in December.
Weeks later, suddenly
I find myself
embedded as part of Etsy's
team in their Slack,
answering questions, talking
about different technical
approaches to building things
out, and actually working out
of their Brooklyn
office once a week.
Notably, Etsy has probably the
best coffee in Brooklyn hands
down.
So from there, we start to
understand the challenges
or problems.
As I'm embedded, I become
part of the culture.
And we start doing hackathons.
One of the teams was
blocked on some deeper
details of Kubernetes.
And we're able to say, OK, let's
bring you into a Google office,
get some Google subject matter
experts on the floor with you,
and actually do a
Kubernetes hackathon.
And in doing so we unblock
the tremendous amount of work
from their backlog that
they had concerns about,
because they simply didn't have
the background or experience.
So we were able to knock
that out right away.
There are some other really
interesting notable things
like Seth Vargo, who is one
of our developer advocates,
did a tech talk on Terraform.
And he did it at Etsy.
And it was so well done
that it is now literally
a piece of Etsy's
onboarding education
for their new engineers so that
they know how to use Terraform.
It was a Q&A session.
Seth came and really provided a
tremendous amount of assistance
in depth, because Seth
used to work at HashiCorp.
Yeah.
And then finally, we
did a lot of engineering
and organizational
cultural alignment.
So I mean like the cultures
are tech companies.
At the end of the day,
we like technology.
We like building solutions.
We like figure out
the right problem.
So there's a lot of
good alignment there.
KEYUR GOVANDE: So
like Danny said,
signed the contract
in December of 2017.
And we had a hard deadline for
shutting down our data centers
about 20 months away.
This was more or less like
a leadership decision.
We did not want to pay.
We had signed a
commit with Google.
We had a data center footprint.
And we did not want to have an
extremely long migration where
we're paying for two things
and doing things slowly
and iteratively over n years.
We felt that we could
move a little bit faster.
And I'll explain more of that
as we go through the talk.
So we essentially had 20 months,
but four of those 20 months
are the busiest period of Etsy.
It's the holiday season.
Etsy's a shopping platform.
And that is our biggest quarter.
We try not to make large
infrastructural changes then
just to avoid instability
for our users.
So preferably, we would
prefer that the large portion
of the migration finish
in the first eight months
so that we have the other eight
months as a fallback in case
we need to fix some things or
have a complete do over even.
So just to remind you
of the ground rules
that we set for ourselves, no
large architectural changes.
This is primarily because
we felt that doing a rewrite
would add a tremendous amount
of risk to the project.
Etsy, like I said before,
has been around since 2005.
The code base has a
lot of kinks in it,
its legacy if you would
be OK calling that.
And we did not feel
that we had the time
to rewrite it into a
microservices architecture
in a way that would
stick with our timelines.
The other thing was to migrate
the fewer systems needed.
Etsy has been around
for many years.
We have lots of systems, a
lot of supporting systems.
And we wanted to see what is
the minimum set of systems
that we can migrate in order
to run etsy.com in GCP.
And thirdly, to stay compliant,
we're a public company,
we had to comply with a set
of regulations and rules
that we could not break.
So this is roughly the
timeline that we came up with.
Start the partnership,
set up a squad,
do all the work to get there,
and then cut over by August
and then do some tuning.
If everything goes smoothly,
then by the time Thanksgiving
hits, the site is running in
GCP and is completely stable.
So Danny briefly touched
on the partnership aspect
so I'm just going to skip
forward to the migration.
So Etsy's infrastructure is
made up of a bunch of teams.
They own their own systems,
their own roadmaps,
and their own tools.
And this creates a problem
for a project as complicated
as a migration, because the
migration throws a wrench
into everyone's plans.
We did not want to
disrupt all of these teams
from doing what they were
doing, which was really mission
critical stuff for etsy.com.
So instead what we came up
with was a migration squad.
We took one or more people
from every one of those teams,
we took away all of their
other responsibilities,
and focused them solely on
this task of moving etsy.com
to the cloud.
This allowed them to basically
not get distracted by the day
to day stuff.
Etsy.com was still running
in the data center, which
meant that there were still
things that needed to be fixed,
issues that came up, site
outages and stuff like that.
But they did not have to
focus on any of those things.
They were solely working
on the migration.
So once we had the
squad set up, we
had to figure out how to work
with the tools in the cloud.
Etsy, as I had
alluded to before,
had a bunch of custom in-house
tooling to manage things
in the data center.
For example, to provision a
box, we wrote our own tools.
It is open sourced, but
it was written by us
to manage the
various permutations
and combinations of hardware.
In Google Cloud, this
was not a problem.
We had to pick a tool.
We picked Terraform, but we
had to learn how to use it.
Google was, again,
a great partner.
Seth Vargo came on
board, taught us
a lot about how to correctly
do Terraform at scale.
But it was something that we
had to learn and figure out.
Another example of this would be
learning how to use Stackdriver
or learning the ins and
outs of the Google network,
if you will.
So just to segue a little bit
into the Etsy architecture,
we've been around
for a long time.
We're a LAMP stack.
That was the hottest
thing to do in 2005.
Linux, Apache, PHP, MySQL.
And because we've been
around for so long,
we have a giant monolith.
It's held together by
our monolithic shards.
And then memcache is our
primary caching tier.
And the code is all
sorts of tangles,
which are really
hard to figure out
and sometimes
causes some issues.
But the good thing about
the Etsy architecture
is that the systems diagram
is relatively straightforward.
There is a load balancer upfront
that serves requests for--
that processes the first--
that is the first stop
in a request to etsy.com.
There's some web servers
that field the request.
They further talk
to some web servers
hidden behind some internal load
balancers eventually talking
to a database.
This is an architecture
that we were
able to reason about really
well about the performance
characteristics, the sort
of what could go wrong.
A premortem was really
easy or relatively
easy to do with this kind
of architecture that we had.
Thing over time that has
been happening at Etsy
is we've been also doing
API first development.
Like I said before,
we're a PHP site
so we don't really have
the idea of an event loop,
but we've emulated that
by using [INAUDIBLE]..
So let me quickly
explain how that works.
So this is-- if you think
of the etsy.com homepage,
there's a bunch of modules on
it, so like a favorites module,
a friends activity, or Etsy
blog content, or promotions,
or personalized content for you.
So when you land on
etsy.com, it actually
splits up internally
into four requests
for all of the different
modules that I described,
which may further break
up into more requests
to actually fetch the data
from the cache or a database.
And all of these are API
tiers that are hidden away.
The nice aspect of
this is it allows
us to scale the system
at every single layer
without affecting
the other layer,
so every single one of these
is a web server and a load
balancer so we're able to
scale up and down as we need
and reason about the system
without needing to understand
the full picture or having
to worry about dependencies
or a tangled tree of code.
So how on earth do we migrate
this thing to Google Cloud?
Just to quickly reiterate,
these were our goals.
And the way that
we talked about it
internally was like maybe we
can set up some read replicas.
Etsy.com, simple application,
why wouldn't a read replica
work?
We discussed this internally
for a very long time,
but it came down
to the fact that,
because of our
monolithic shards,
we had come to rely
on some behaviors
like immediately read
after write consistency.
This would be really
hard to replicate
if we were to spin up replicas
of our data center setup
in GCP that would be many
tens of milliseconds away
from the data center,
which would mean
that their consistency
would not be
accurate to within a
millisecond or even
within a single transaction.
Another thing that
we discussed was
to maybe spin up
active active, so keep
one copy of etsy.com
running in the data center
and then spin up a
completely active copy in GCP
in multiple regions and redirect
traffic maybe over like GOIP
based on where the
user is coming from.
But again, the monolith and
the tangled dependencies
made this really
hard for us to do
without having to do a rewrite.
And one of our key
goals was to not do
a rewrite of the application.
So what we ended up doing,
or what we landed on,
was a sort of lift and shift.
As I said before,
like the application
we felt we could reason
about reasonably well.
So a lift and shift was actually
a perfectly reasonable approach
for where we were in time.
Remember we only had
20 months to migrate.
And our application
was a monolith
that we did not feel we
could rewrite in that period.
But the problem with
the lift and shift
was that there is no clean
way to switch traffic over.
If you had an
active active copy,
you could bring all of them up
and then turn one of them down.
No one would notice.
But with a lift and shift,
that was really not an option.
So we instead proactively
communicated with our sellers
that we're going to take
a maintenance window.
The site will be unavailable
for a portion of time
while we migrated to Google
Cloud and brought it up there.
This is not, again, anyone's
first preferred approach.
But we felt that given the
constraints that we were under
and basically time system
limitations that this
was the best approach for Etsy.
And being proactive
with our sellers
meant that we did
not necessarily
cause them any surprise.
Like we didn't just go down.
We gave them enough
notice that this
was going to happen so they
were able to plan for it.
So once we got all
of the tooling,
once we got comfortable
with all of the tooling
and getting things
spun up in the cloud,
we entered the functional
testing and the load
and performance testing phase.
So etsy.com is a
website driven primarily
by load in the holiday season.
So we had some expectations
about that load.
We made sure to test for at
least 2x the traffic in GCP
once we had all of the
systems up and running.
And basically, even if
you're in the cloud,
things that you focus on in
the data center still matter.
For example, CP architectures.
Like in the DC, all of our
boxes were really custom.
We had them tuned really
well for our work load.
And we found that we had to do
some of that in GCP as well.
GCP offers, at
least at the time,
three classes of CPU hardware.
And we found that Skylake was
the most performant for us.
But it was not the default in
the region that we were in.
So as we did load and
performance testing,
we found this but we were
again able to tune it
with Terraform to always
pick the one that we needed.
And it was a pretty
decent 10% win
in, sorry, the capacity for us.
And at scale, even 99.9%
might not be enough.
So the Google global load
balancer at that time
had a bug where at extremely
long tail of requests,
the latency would spike a lot
because of some discovery.
Google was a fantastic partner
who worked with us on this.
We told them we had an issue.
They engaged us.
They set up all of
the packet captures
at the various levels
of the hypervisor
to figure this bug
out and fixed it.
But this was, again,
like a thing that
was a learning curve for Etsy.
We were always in
the data center.
We knew we owned everything
so once that request
entered our network,
we had full control.
And this was something
that we had to adjust to.
If there was an
issue, how do you
work with your partner to
figure out what the issue is?
And how do you remediate that?
So a quick segue into the
most amazing outage probably
of my career.
So while we were
setting up Google Cloud
and a parallel infrastructure
in Google Cloud
to do so to do all
of this testing,
we had staged the IP in
preparation for the cut over.
The way that we had done it
was we have two DNS providers.
One of them supports
a do not serve flag.
Basically what that
means is never serve
this DNS record no matter what.
But the other DNS provider did
not support a do not serve flag
so instead we added it
on into the provider
with a ratio of zero.
What zero means is
run health checks.
And if the other
IP address is down,
then you're OK
serving this record.
As it happens, after
we had done this,
etsy.com had a small outage.
For about 10 minutes,
the main site
was down because we
we're doing something.
It didn't work.
But what happened was we served
the GCP test infrastructure IP
to our customers.
The good thing was that
that infrastructure was not
scaled to handle traffic at the
rate at which the traffic had
landed, so it
immediately fell over.
But for a few of
our customers they
saw a slightly
unusual experience,
like the colors were are all
wrong because we were using
blue to signify that this is
a test infrastructure, not
the Etsy orange.
So it caused some emails
to our support site.
But in like true Etsy fashion,
we celebrated this outage.
It was completely unexpected
behavior for everyone involved.
And the engineer who
was most proximate to it
won the Etsy's coveted
three-armed sweater
award for causing the most
spectacular outage of the year.
So moving on the
timeline finally coming
to the actual cut
over, we did all
of the functional
testing, load testing,
in order to gain confidence.
And we realized
that the only way
that we would know if
this would truly work
was to send live traffic at it.
No amount of testing can mimic
the complexity of production.
And the Etsy app
is complex enough
that we could not cover
every single thing
through simulation.
So we felt that we had
to at least cut over
once to learn more about what
are the hardest problems here
that we have not found basically
that our engineers may not even
be aware of.
So the way that we planned for
it was to have a soft release.
This was a new thing for Etsy.
We are a continuous
deployment shop.
We deploy 30 times a day.
But in preparation
for cut over, we
communicated to all
of our engineers
that for a couple of days
things will be moving slower,
so it would be a soft release
where only P1 [INAUDIBLE]
would go out and then we would
enter a full freeze where
no changes except those
required to basically set up
the cut over for
success would be allowed
and then there would be
a period of heightened
on call monitoring.
A lot of teams had
signed up for a rotation
so that they would help
observe the site once we
were running in GCP.
DANNY ROSEN: Yeah.
So that was all Etsy's approach
to the cut over process,
a pretty different one.
Google also had an approach.
So I think the
important context here
is that Etsy ran their own
data centers, everything
in their data centers.
So if any network
issues happened,
they had network engineers
that knew what was going on.
Now Etsy is taking
the responsibility
of effectively running
their data centers
and giving it to Google.
That's scary.
So what we did to
support them is we
went in and masqueraded
effectively as Etsy engineers.
And we went through a two week
immersed training in Etsy.
Myself and a couple
of other Googlers
went in and then said,
OK, we understand
the lay of the land,
how the systems work.
We provided what we're
just calling artifacts.
Right.
We actually created
system overviews,
product overviews, and gave
that to our support teams
that they had context on
what to know if Etsy called
and something was broken,
specifically for cut over but,
hey, even after they
still have these artifacts
so they have some
system archeology
and knowledge of state.
Another thing that's
important here
is that Etsy has an
interesting engineering
culture and Etsyan terms.
And every company
has corp speak,
so we got that down
to you in a glossary.
So that's one part
of the work we did.
The other part was
we created what
we call the war
room, which basically
was a cut over day team approach
to connecting the Etsy team,
us, who were actually on
site at 3:00 in the morning
and the support teams
that were monitoring.
A couple days before,
myself, a couple of others,
were on a gigantic email
thread to hundreds of Googlers
saying Etsy is going live
this weekend at 3:00 AM.
Effectively, be ready.
SRE teams, our product
teams, our engineering teams
all pretty much had an
awareness of the situation.
And we did it.
We got on site.
We came in numbers.
There were three of us.
It was 3:00 in the morning.
And we worked together to
start the cut over process.
Probably one of the most
important factors here
was that we had donuts.
In having donuts, we were
able to energize the team
so I wanted to
thank specifically
the sales team at Google
for providing the donuts.
Thanks, guys.
KEYUR GOVANDE: Cool.
So cut over day.
We picked a Sunday morning.
It was 3:00 AM.
It was determined that
this was the lowest traffic
time of the week for us.
It would be the least impactful
to do a cut over at this time
because we had planned on being
down for about four hours.
So the rough idea
was start at 3:00 AM,
turn off etsy.com
in the data center,
do some validation and
testing in GCP on the info
that we have there, and then
slowly ramp up traffic to GCP
and then make a decision
about whether to stay or not.
As you can imagine, turning
off a website is not trivial.
So etsy.com has been like a
continuously operated site
for many years.
And there are a lot of systems
that are always running
to make everything smooth.
So like offline processing jobs,
asynchronous jobs, big data
jobs, database backups,
all of these things
that we had to plan
for and execute
in a particular-- like in
an exact series of steps
in order to do it safely.
Because we obviously
did not want
to lose any of our customer
information, nor did
we want our customers to see
weird behavior on the site.
So the way that we did
it, we blocked them off
at the CDN layer so that
everyone who's coming
sees a uniform experience.
That the Etsy site is
down for maintenance,
and then revert to their
databases, their DBAs,
and other SRE-ish
roles to make sure
that everything turns off
in just the right order.
And we did this.
It took us about
an hour and a half,
exactly what we had planned for.
But the site was done
correctly and all of the data,
more importantly, was replicated
to GCP so that we could
bring the site back up in GCP.
So around 4:30 AM
we did a cutover.
The site was running in GCP,
but only for internal users,
only for all of our engineers
who were there to test.
And as these things happen,
we ran into something
that we had never
run into testing.
We ran out of memory on some
key offline processing systems
that we had not
specifically tested.
But they were important enough,
as we found during the cutover,
that we could not basically
launch to our real users.
It was also like
4:30 in the morning.
No one had slept for the night,
everyone was really groggy,
and we felt that we
could not figure this out
in time to make our window.
So, unfortunately,
we rolled back.
But this was good from the way
that we approached the problem
because we discovered
something new.
We discovered that
we had not covered,
in enough detail, an
area of the site that we
needed to do better in
order to try this again.
And why did we
have to try again?
Because of this.
We had eight months
to do this right.
We were already in August and
if we didn't do it in August
then we would have to wait
four months, until January,
before we were able to
have another shot at this.
So we felt like that if we were
able to address the problems
that we saw, that we needed to
try again, at least once, so
that all of the people who
had worked really hard,
their work would pay off without
having to wait for n months.
Those n months could mean
many different things,
like code would have
changed in that time.
Infrastructure in
the data center
would have drifted in that time.
And we would have had to sort
of redo a whole bunch of things
if we waited that long.
So after fixing and doing
a bunch more testing,
we decided to give ourselves
another shot at the cutover.
We made a couple of changes.
We decided to start earlier in
the night, so start at 1:00 AM.
And we gave ourselves
a six hour window
to do the migration, rather than
the four hours from last time.
We felt that this
added enough buffer
that if we run into issues, that
we would be able to fix them.
So we turned off etsy.com.
We had gotten really
good at this point,
having done it twice, like once
off and then once on again.
And we ended up finding new
errors in the validation
testing phase.
As an example, run some daemons
that had too few threads.
And this was causing
some backups, some delays
in critical operations.
We fixed that.
In another case we
had too many threads.
And this was, again,
causing system instability.
But because we had set
ourselves enough time,
we were able to find and
remedy these on the spot.
And finally, this
time around, we
were able to ramp up
real users to the site.
So around like 5:30 AM real
users in a slow trickle
started to see
etsy.com work in GCP.
At which point it became--
after we had been running
in GCP for a few hours, this
was sort of a key decision,
which is, should we stay?
We were learning new
things, as I will show
in some slides that follow.
But do we stay or
do we roll back?
Are things good enough that
we can stay here and continue
to learn?
Or are they not good
enough on some axis
that we need to roll back?
The axis that we had
set for ourselves
were operational stability,
whether it was burning out
our ops teams, or is it
impacting our sales too much
in a way that we can measure,
or is the performance on GCP not
that great.
The performance
one is interesting
because, like I had said
before in my talk, in our data
center everything was really
tuned for optimal performance.
We had the exact set of
hardware that would give us
the best performance for our
databases, for our memcaches,
for our web servers.
And in GCP, there
is less variability,
like you only have a
certain class of boxes
and certain classes of CPUs.
And we felt like we did a
lot of synthetic testing,
but that can never capture
the complexity of [INAUDIBLE]..
We only covered
80% of the traffic.
And the other 20%, the
long tail, we had no idea--
or we had some idea,
but not an exact idea
of how that would perform.
So it was like a
big variable for us.
But we found that the
performance is actually
quite all right.
So all the way on the right
is performance in GCP.
The two blank spots in the
middle are two cutover windows.
But as you can see, the
perf was not that bad.
It was within bounds
that we had set ourselves
that this would be OK
and we can tolerate this
and we can make this
better over time,
but we'll continue
running in GCP.
So now we entered the
sort of tuning phase
before the big Black
Friday, Cyber Monday.
There was a ton of things that
we were discovering in GCP,
in production.
So optimizing system calls.
GCP, and any cloud provider,
is a massively virtualized
environment.
In the data center we were
running on bare metal.
We found that if we optimized
away some system calls,
it would make our performance
on some key systems
really predictable, like really
smooth and not as jagged.
So we did that.
The other key win for
us was, MySQL in GCP
had some really unusual
behavior on new mutexes which
was only visible when there
was sufficient amount of read
and write traffic to
this, that we were simply
unable to replicate
through synthetic testing
but that showed
up in production.
And we worked with Google
engineers and internal DBAs
and other systems-minded folks
to figure this out and fix it
by adjusting kernel parameters
and MySQL variables.
The other thing is,
again, the network
showed up as a huge factor.
Google's network is a
software defined network.
It is not routers and
switches in the way
that it would be
in a data center.
And at extremely large
percentiles, 99.999%,
if you do it often
enough and at scale then
those network jitter slash
variances really matter.
So in the case of memcache, for
example, which we use really
heavily, we found
that the latency
would spike from
a few microseconds
to many hundreds
of milliseconds.
And this would matter
for our application.
This was another
thing that we just
had to go to prod
to discover because
like the sort of
request patterns
that prod has was really hard
to mimic in a test environment,
in a simulation.
But again, Google were
great partners with us.
We engaged them, they did
all the packet captures,
they figured out what was the
issue over some period of time,
and they fixed it.
It was actually a bug in their
SDN that we found for them.
DANNY ROSEN: Thanks.
KEYUR GOVANDE: So this
is roughly the time line.
We got through all
the tuning phase
and we made it to Cyber
Monday without any issues,
like we survived in slush.
More than survived, we were
able to scale up and down
during Cyber Monday
as we needed to
in order to manage all of the
load that was on the site.
And it worked out the
way that we had hoped.
So some observations
from being in the Cloud.
We've been running in the Cloud
for about seven months now
and we've learned some things.
So long-lived flows.
In the data center,
again, this was something
that we did not
have to care about.
If a service opened a
connection to another service
it could go on for
weeks, hours, months,
and it would not matter.
But in Google software-defined
network this was a problem.
A connection can only
be idle for 10 minutes
before the SDN kills it.
This was something that we had
to discover the hard way, where
we had a bunch of services
that were acting weirdly.
But it was something that we
could adopt to, like using
[INAUDIBLE] or using pings
allowed us to work around this.
But this was a thing
that we had to learn
and all of the service owners
had to adopt specifically to.
On the plus side, live
migrations, really good.
If Google needs to do
maintenance on a host,
they will live migrate
you off to another host.
And this works even for things
like memcache and MySQL,
which have large memory
pools and a lot of traffic.
And the blip is really tiny.
So like this is something
that made our jobs really easy
from an operational perspective.
And lastly, infinite capacity.
The Cloud promises to be
infinite, but at scale
it really is not.
DANNY ROSEN: Yeah.
KEYUR GOVANDE: What
do you think, Danny?
DANNY ROSEN: So I
can speak to that.
So I think that's part of the
narrative of Cloud, right.
Which is, oh, I can
just burst and I
have all this capacity
and everything I need
and all the CPUs I need and
all the RAM and everything
is there for me.
Right?
So that's the Cloud
vision, all right?
And that works, by the way,
if you want like 500 cores.
Sounds good, you want more?
500 cores, 700 cores,
1,000 cores, go for it.
But when you want 50,000
cores and you want it now,
it's a little different.
And I think when we start
thinking about that,
there's two layers.
The first is people.
All right?
We want to give you all the
capacity we can do, just
to support your activities.
But there are many
other people who
also want 50,000 cores of the
same thing that you might.
So, thinking about
that idea, you
start to realize that, wow,
it's not just 50,000 for me.
It's 50,000 for a lots
of other large customers.
And then also it's kind of
reasonable to say that hardware
is still a thing that we need
to buy and put in our data
centers.
And that takes time.
That was outlined
here, too, right?
At the end of the day, Cloud is
just somebody else's computer.
We need more computers.
So infinite capacity makes
sense, but at the right scale,
rather than at a massive one.
KEYUR GOVANDE: And
Danny and other Googlers
were good partners to
help us figure out like,
how much heads-up do we need to
give them if we needed 50,000
cores when we needed them.
So this was something
that we had to learn.
Our cycle was a year before.
Now it was much smaller,
we could give them
a heads-up maybe
a month in advance
and we would have the
hardware, rather than 12 months
in advance as it was before.
So coming to an end,
circles of success.
DANNY ROSEN: Yeah, so I think--
we added this slide in because
we wanted to call out, I think,
one of the fundamental factors
of a large scale migration
of a system like this.
That it takes a village.
So there were Googlers, a
tremendous amount of Googlers,
who put in their time and effort
to make sure this happened.
And it happened
pretty seamlessly,
not just for Google, but really
for Etsy and Etsy's customers.
And then there's the Etsyans.
Now what kind of
interesting is, you really
have these three circles.
And I'll attribute this to
Chris, who's in the front row
here, he came up with this idea.
Which was, there are
three circles of influence
or ownership or impact--
we'll call it three
circles of impact in Etsy.
The first is kind of
your core team, right.
This is your squad.
Not only are these people
there to develop the systems
and the ideas around them, but
they're also on-call, right,
because they have
the deepest context.
So that's the
first kind of core.
And that's like maybe
five, seven people or so.
And then outside of
that, as Keyur mentioned,
you had a team of people
who were testing the site.
Like going to etsy.com,
when it was live at 4:00
in the morning, and making sure
that the manual testing covered
all the edge cases
and use cases they
didn't think of in the
first place, right.
These people are giving
up a lot of time.
They're coming
[INAUDIBLE] beforehand.
And they're there to
help and make an impact.
So this is kind
of another layer.
And then finally,
outside of that,
you have this broad layer of
people in the organization that
supported everyone.
You had management,
you had teammates
who took on work that
other folks would say,
"Hey, listen, I can't do this
because I'm on the squad.
Can you help me
out," even people
in security who
are on the outside,
actually letting people into
the building at 3:00 AM.
It takes a village.
And I think it's worth
saying that and acknowledging
that a Cloud migration, really
any systems migration to Cloud,
is best done as a team.
And, notably, value
should be attributed
to the people who did that.
All right?
So even the security person who
woke up at 2:30 in the morning
to get to the
Brooklyn office should
be given credit because he was
there also to make that happen.
KEYUR GOVANDE: All right.
So, as I said speaking before,
they did a lift and shift,
but it is not where
we want to end up.
We did a lift and shift for
a bunch of reasons, which
was to move fast and
to move in confidence
and to introduce less
risk into what was already
a fairly complex migration.
But we don't want to
rest on our laurels,
we don't want to stay there.
We want to make things better.
So we want to be
refactoring our monolith
to fit better in the Cloud, to
use Cloud-native technologies.
We also want to get a good
handle on cost management.
Being in the data
center, the cost equation
was relatively straightforward.
It was, you buy some
hardware and then you
use it for three years,
or you don't use it,
but it doesn't matter.
Whereas in GCP,
it really matters
if the box is up and running
and you're not using it.
And we have a lot
of technical debt
that we need to pay down,
like not a lot of it--
I mean, some of it added because
of the migration but some of it
that existed way before, that
we feel that we can now pay down
much more effectively.
For example, if we wanted to
spin up new servers in the data
center, we would have to
follow the usual Waterfall
Model of placing those
orders early enough so
that we were able to have
the capacity needed to effect
any kind of refactoring.
In GCP it's a lot
more straightforward.
You spin up some
Terraform config,
as long as Google has the
heads up about the capacity
that we need, it's
there and were
able to execute and iterate
much more quickly and with less
valence friction.
And also look at
our org structures.
We're running in the Cloud.
SRE is a thing that we want to
adopt, the practices around it,
around building reliable
systems in the Cloud,
that we did not necessarily
need to focus on when
we were in the data center.
So some of the things that
Etsy's working on now that
were past it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]